>> Education is the ultimate poverty eradication
tool.
When you know better, you tend to do better.
We all know this.
We all know that in Africa if you give a woman
two years of primary
school education in a village in Africa, you
lift the entire village
out of poverty.
We know the power of education in China and
the power of education in
the developing world, yet we do so little.
Yet we tend to have ready, fire, aim.
We wait until the last minute.
We don't make our first investments.
Why don't governments do this?
Why don't they make this a larger priority?
In my book, Love Leadership, a New Way to
Lead in a Fear-Based World, I
talk about laziness as well, fear as a lazy
bastard.
There's two things in the world there's love
and there's fear.
And you don't love, you fear.
And fear's first cousin is laziness.
And laziness' best friend is short-termism,
a focus on me and not we.
What do we have to get versus what we have
to give?
And this immediate gratification and greed.
And so it is our short-term nature it is the
immediacy of politics
versus the long-term nature of public service
that has got us wrapped
in this vicious cycle.
And what I've said, if you want to make a
lot of money, you want to do
really well, there's nothing better for you
or worse for society than
oppression in the short term.
But in the long term, you hit a wall and we've
hit a wall around the
world.
I keep saying this is not a recession; it's
a reset.
And so we're going to have to start making
long-term investments in
everything, the environment, in our economy,
financial literacy is an
example of a long-term investment and education
is the ultimate way to
break the back of poverty.
In America, 30 percent of all students who
are dropping out of high
school in the largest economy in the world.
50 percent of all urban kids are dropping
out of high school and
70 percent of black men are dropping out of
high school.
This is an economic death sentence and it
is not sustainable.
We need to make smart sexy again.
We need to make a long-term investment to
reframe education and smart
sexy and cool.
And I guess the last thing I'll say is developing
countries where kids
are dropping out of high school -- where in
developing countries kids
are just trying to get into school, but in
developed countries, they're
jumping out of high school.
They're dropping out out of school because
they don't think that
education is relevant to their future.
How do you make it relevant?
Show kids how to prosper, how to succeed,
how to do well, and even how
to get rich if they want to legally.
That's financial literacy, free enterprise
and capitalism, ownership,
opportunity, and entrepreneurship.
Even if you're dealing with a drug dealer,
he's not dumb.
He understands import/export, supply/demand,
wholesale/retail, customer
service, security.
You're not talking about a dumb kid.
You're talking about a mis-directed kid.
So let's give them a role model.
Let's give them a relevant education.
Let's give them the opportunity to apply those
skills and to improve
their life, and we will see education be the
ultimate long-term
investment in our society and that's doing
well and doing good.
Doing well by doing good.
If you want to help, go to 5MK.org.
Fivemillionkids.org.
Help Quincy Jones, Andrew Young, and myself
to make smart sexy again.
Thank you very much.